- I am so excited to have the chance
to share my passion for design
and decorating with you.
In another life,
I would have been a full
on interior designer.
I'm obsessed with creating fun new spaces
and redecorating my home, friends' homes,
and now maybe some of your homes,
if I could be so lucky?
This is our first ever Designed by Drew.
Okay.
Essential workers have become the backbone
of the country this year,
and we have so much to thank them for.
One family right here in our
backyard has been selfless
during this time as all five
members have been going to work
every single day.
Please meet the Copenings.
(upbeat music)
- Don't let this, you know, us
sitting down here, fool you.
We are a crazy bunch.
We are just electric at times, you know.
Everybody's a little
spicy in their own way,
and we just love to have a good time.
You know, you never know what to expect
in the Copening house.
- My name is Michael Copening,
AKA Chocolate Thunder, baby!
- I'm Lachelle, Mama Bear, AKA Chelley!
- Michael Copening Jr., AKA Mike Mike,
so good you gotta say it twice.
- Shakiyah Copening,
I am the middle child
and the favorite child.
(family laughing)
- And I'm Jay, AKA Jay Smooth, the baby.
- [Family] And we are the Copenings!
(uplifting music)
- Me, my husband, my children,
we're all essential workers.
I am a United States postal clerk.
- I knew I was a front line worker
when I looked at all my neighbors
and they wasn't going to work
in the morning. (laughing)
But I knew somebody got
to take care of the sick.
So if I don't do my job,
then somebody else can't do their job.
Mike Mike was like me,
a directional transportation technician.
You may not know what it is,
but it's the bus operator.
That's my son, y'all.
You have my daughter, she's
in the board of education.
She takes care of the kids.
Jayquan, he works in a nursing home.
- I'm grateful that we were
not physically affected
by the virus.
It really had me so
worried and so concerned.
- At first, I didn't take
the COVID too serious
until I learned that I
lost a close coworker.
It made me just say, this is for real.
- That's one of the things
of being a frontline
essential worker is that, you know,
you're not only worried about the people
that you're in the house
with, but you're worried
about the people that
they're connected to.
- At my nursing home,
I was close to many
residents who passed away.
It was this one resident
that I really got close to,
probably my best friend there.
He got really sick and all the nurses
and everything thought
it was over for him.
And I prayed for him.
I had my whole family pray for him
and he actually made it through.
- We are a family that
supports one another.
So if one of us is down
and somebody need a prayer,
so we all band together as a family.
And we said, we're gonna
pray for that person.
- During the pandemic,
I felt it was just more than
just taking people to work.
It was just who I was taking the work,
bringing in the front line
workers, officers, nurses,
doctors, you know, all the above.
- This summer for Hero Day,
I wore an MTA uniform
because I wanted to celebrate
the fact that my brother
and my dad were out there
every day, driving
essential workers to work
and I wanted to celebrate them
because they were my heroes.
(upbeat music)
- The house that we're in right now
is a very special place to me.
I was born and raised there.
And now I have the
pleasure of raising my kids
in the same house.
So we all have the same experiences.
- During this pandemic, we
had to find new safe places
for our family to spend time,
and the backyard was our place.
We have that karaoke
night, almost all the time
when we in the backyard.
- We learned a lot of card games.
Everybody was learning how to cook,
and it was kind of like
back to our safe space.
- The Copenings, we're home
safe and sound from work,
headed to the backyard for a barbecue!
- The backyard is my kingdom back there.
I do my grilling back there.
We're going to call this
Cooking with Chocolate.
I could smoke it, I could bake it,
I could fry it, whatever
you want, you can get it.
- We always wanted our backyard renovated
since we spend so much time back here.
We just haven't had the opportunity
because we're always working.
- During the summer seasons,
that's where we go to enjoy
food, music, and just relax.
- We have a lot of fun,
but God has blessed us
to raise three strong, responsible kids
that know the meaning family.
- I love this family!
So while the family was having
a good time at the park,
they had no idea what was
happening at their house.
We sent an entire team
to dig up their lawn,
bring a new appliances,
and new patio furniture.
And the craziest part,
we did all of this in just five hours.
Look at this crew!
It actually took weeks to set
up, but execute in five hours.
And I can't wait to see their faces
when we reveal their new backyard to them.
(upbeat music)